[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
or we talk about whatever we want
welcome back
Lauren why is Lauren your stage name or
your real name um misspelling how trippy
is this the spelling is my station oh
yeah I remember I remember it's terrible
um don't ever change your name ever even
just change money for marriage like I
can't get out like getting a new
passport getting a new license has been
like the worst did you know I'm a guy I
didn't have to do exactly I don't work -
Nikki wants some guys that changed their
name to the wife's name really why no
one I don't want to know them - let me
ask you this we know one guy that would
took the average of the both I know one
knows well I know that guy - I know I
don't know let me ask you you got stuck
in a freezer oh wait what she mentioned
this when she first heard up and I
couldn't stop thinking about it so I
used to work at Red Robin Robin like in
college in North Carolina and I would go
back in the freezer and like eat cheese
super sanitary and one day I was like a
mouse stealing cheese and I got knocked
in and it was like the end of the night
so nobody was in the kitchen and I ended
myselfi Nami because this was like 2006
so it probably didn't even have like an
iPhone this was like a phone you didn't
keep with you all the time there's no
like inside like I don't know why it
feels like really not safe for forever
reason I couldn't get the door open and
I just like sat there and like pounded
and there was no window oh [ __ ] so I
just pounded for like 10 minutes and
then somebody finally came in oh good
and then they were like yeah I was 10
minutes but they were like they couldn't
even get mad at me for stealing cheese
cuz I just got locked in their freezer
and they didn't want to like loss like I
got hungry yeah
yeah ten minutes of survival yeah I
needed something higher to keep me warm
ten minutes I'd already like drank my
own pea I just survived Allah did you
time it ten minutes a whole last ten
minutes that would probably feel like
two hours for me yeah who knows
obviously it may have been like thirty
seconds but in my mind it was like I was
like losing oxygen
how does it even have locks on the
fridge it was a lot it like just didn't
have a handle on the inside or something
he just wouldn't open it was like a one
yeah why do walks inside yeah hey I
don't remember watch there was but it
had to be like one of those things you
pull or it's on the side or something on
the side oh like an emergency latch and
Isis he should teach all the employees
too expensive to do that I feel like
yeah sorry I feel like those things are
like freezer locks are purely designed
to kill like 230 people a year like why
else is exist behind it what those
people probably are dumb and we don't
need them around anyway me like I did my
could die in a freezer I deserved that
dumb you live because you pound yeah I
would have just try to start a fire or
something in there keep me warm is it as
cold as the produce section in Costco
oh yeah it's cool you know you kind of
walk into a refrigerator you'll be was
fine until you're like in there and
you're like oh [ __ ] can I ask you slowly
at Red Robin so bad that you have to go
eat cheese out of a fridge I know that's
a great question you sneak some fries or
something from at a bottomless price
right was it cheddar cheese or was it
American cheese a variety it was like
there's like Colby jack chatter only it
was like 20 for a cheese cheese I don't
know it you had your own cheese plate it
got a little wide here - cheese - steel
cheese Ben fries they like monitor that
[ __ ] the modern fries but they're
bottomless for the patrons but if you
ever had to tell pages like hey man and
bottomless does not like come here
forever please yeah oh yeah really
people take advantage of free fry fills
trash people are my favorite and like
north
like man those people just love a good
deal you know yeah they're coming in to
save money that's true so we're guys
Hometown Buffet in high school and there
would be people that we'd have to ask
like you know we're we're gonna close
you've been here since breakfast they
stay for like two or three meals yeah
that's like in Vegas you go to a buffet
and it's like a million dollars so you
stay from breakfast to lunch and they're
like we're flipping over to lunch you
got to go and I'm like no oh if you stay
from lunch to dinner you can do that you
pay the lunch price but go toward the
tail end of it 3:30 you just chill the
dinner stuff that's when you think you
got a deal cuz you paid $29 for it
instead of 60 and said yeah 45 or
whatever it's like you still got [ __ ]
either way yeah Vegas is still laughing
at you when you try me a bathing suit
dress I also do you guys ever take the
Pottermore quiz find a white house
you're in I don't know what that is oh
you know everything about Marvel but you
look at me like I don't know I do yeah
here's the thing nerds one and we
inherited the earth and so like I look
down on you yeah no but Potterheads are
like our little kid a little kid brother
or something get them well there's I
mean unfortunately all of the ones who
are older they're with yeah they all
grew up there all but they're not
invited to comic-con so that's where the
real nerds are yeah what's Steven Steve
honestly from afar if I didn't know you
as a person uh you're all right just
your look you're a [ __ ] nerd in my
mind I'm a nerd yeah you think I'm a
nerd no [ __ ] what are you talking about
hey geo you look like a tall amazonian I
got you yeah man also be like
quarterback high school bully Oh
high school boy laughter that's what my
wife says she says you look like Philip
Rivers from the Chargers but he like
kind of II quit football and he works at
Jiffy Lube
Wow that's so good if you have a Paolo
Soleri it's pretty good I mean now you
don't look as nerdy without the glasses
thank you
isn't everyone just a nerd now there's
no like yeah I would wear no hair
partnership but yeah it's fun in high
school I was in marching band and all of
our editors from homecoming court was
all from the March band because we had
an army of people to vote so like every
year
marching band was like 300 people wanted
to play Wow tell me a long story
I played the oboe I was a I was a
privately trained oboist but you can't
March with an oboe it's very delicate
Reed yeah a clarinet I played clarinet I
started on the clarinet but my first
year marching I passed out because it
was really hot banking hot so then they
put me in the pit and I play the viola
phone-banking
oh yeah I did band camp from our Japan
and I also went to Virginia Tech like
every summer for band camp
oh yeah it's the [ __ ] well there's
like baseball camps there at the same
time like a horny little eighth grader
in so that one time at band camp is real
Wow I'm not with the not the other band
nerds like with the other cool camp lied
I lied to the baseball camp that I was
there for softball camp there's all
these different camps like I picture you
wearing a [ __ ] Harry Potter cloak you
have the Harry Potter glasses on and
then some Harry Potter nerd comes up to
you and you're out of my weight [ __ ]
nerd and you go up another like it was
like a hot football guy well in high
school
there weren't it like it wasn't cool to
be like Harry Potter our Harry Potter
fan now it's like cool yeah to be like I
mean that wasn't the time we're just
having us one strap on your backpack was
cool and yeah later
yeah the one where you have the backpack
all the way to your ass that was my
generation in I'm surprised people
aren't walking around like this I just
found out that you could like tighten a
book bag like my husband rocket at the
airport cuz I just thought you always
wear it that low and he was like I was
like man my back hurts he was it tighten
your strap
he'd tighten him all the way to the top
and it looked like a nerd food is fine I
was like oh my god this is life-changing
he's your husband a bomber fan uh he has
read all the books and watched all the
movies oh that's a via the dog's name
he's named after the founder of Griffin
Barstow
well he doesn't look like a nerd my dog
my husband was the high school
quarterback and he loves to be like oh
you married the marching band NERD
married why did he marry the marching
band NERD I can hear you no no I'm just
saying that you and you think about the
stereotype dog you don't want to marry
the cheerleader after she's 25 wait what
you have to because she's pregnant yeah
that's true yeah I tried out for
cheerleading I got cut I knew like
you're more of an oboist yeah I think
they just knew they were like oh we
can't have that crossover is just like
stay with your kind so like you pass out
in the Sun you give me a [ __ ] machine
later doing got here we'll play the
xylophone in the dark you're like
tumbling and then you pass out in the
middle of it
big narcoleptic
okay bps cheerleader
wait so you grew up in North Carolina
like around
I just know rally but Fayetteville not
like an hour
oh what's the correct way to pronounce
Fayetteville or Vietnam because there's
an army base there and so there's a lot
of GIS that's a big army transient town
so they called Vietnam how far is that
away from a place called Camp Lejeune or
Camp Johnson I can't play gin is that
employers at North or South Carolina
North Carolina Jacksonville Jackson oh
yeah two months Jacksonville North
Carolina
oh is it near the coast it's near Myrtle
Beach yes Greensboro Greensboro okay
where's that in North Carolina somewhere
oh okay
I was traveling to battle me I'm like
high school to college my parents still
live there but I my first like 15 years
I lived in Northern Virginia Myrtle
Beach is white trash Hawaii did for us
yeah it's fun it sounds dull it's fine I
want to go trash Hawaii is even like
very complimentary it's even compared to
Hawaii
well you don't I mean it's like like
they're there Hawaii their vacation yeah
yeah yeah that's more like when you're
on the East Coast as I grew up in
Virginia they go to Myrtle Beach for
their Spring Break we went to my baby
Spring Break High School that's before I
even drank
I got burn with a cigarette would see me
dancing with a cigarette burn my arm oh
let's do that that was scar yeah it's
right here
oh no that was a freckle I got removed I
[Laughter]
have to bust yourself you did have to do
that so it's like a cigar scar is huge
ya know we've been to rally and they
actually have some really good
Vietnamese food but just in general
southern food is like so damn good we
went about Django's we went to some
barbecue joint it was really cool I love
North Carolina so
it's so good it's like bigger they I
like it already yeah anything vinegar
you okay where do we go was it Duke or
no sorry I went to Carolina so every
time I heard Duke I'm like I'm like it
no we went to the other one right you
can see oh and she said I was he forgot
it wasn't rally she stays in Raleigh
it's a big school for school isn't wrong
he's like a mom calling my mom Bart tell
me about you getting in a car accident
when you tease this to me two weeks ago
and you never tire I remember everything
I left that day going we didn't tell
Steve but I think you'd hold on to it I
always hold on to everything
uh the one where you got mosquito so we
know there's no way there's no way I was
not there I don't know but it's still a
weeping so we as in all of us that
invest in like the tea stuff the sip
stuff we were on our way to a meeting
coming from our own I don't know places
of origin and I was just driving through
Pasadena and you know those lights were
it's red and then when it turns green in
order to turn you kind of slowly move to
the center and then you wait to like oh
it's clear and then you turn so it was
green now and so we both moved to the
center and we both are at a complete
stop and then I started getting these
crazy mosquito itches cuz I got bit like
several times on my lake so I was like
scratching my leg like crazy in the
country mosquitoes my foot slipped off
the accelerator so my I hit the car in
front of me and then when I came out
she's like oh my god you jolted me and
then I'm so I'm so sorry like and then
she was like she felt kind of like
discombobulated and I'm like it's like
crazy and then she was I guess she also
got scared cuz it's her husband's
company car so she was like um oh no
it's a car okay but there was no
scratches because I came from like uh
pretty much the complete stop and then
it was just funny that it was the
mosquitoes that I was scratching yeah
and she was okay she was okay we call
that a car accident
well she
I think the point of this story is how
stupid that must feel like you should
always if you're at a stop keep your
foot on the brake like it's okay to
screw up but it says sometimes it's
really itchy and then you know like the
car like sometime he hasn't done this
one like I was in the car huh
what if it's really itchy and sometimes
you know what you put on the brake yeah
and if your foots on the brake sometimes
it's not all the way down if it's not
all the way down in our car moves for
really slowly like this is the second
time that that's happened I mean the
first time mosquitoes [ __ ] you up
again no was it mosquito I don't even
know what happened to you by the bus I'm
in the passenger is that tips I mean the
passenger side gave it to him and then I
don't know why he thought same situation
but for some reason he thought they had
left there's something and he just kind
of guess and he just hit them again who
you who's this what you get I'm twice
the same car when did I ever get a car
accident with you in it well the one I
just told them yeah she just told the
story right now I would never when you
hit the guy and then you backed up and
you hit him again
yeah like sorry it's great there's no
scratch you're all good then you're like
oh wait hold on no that's yeah there's a
scratch now I started god I wouldn't be
surprised if that happened I'd be like
yeah now I've seen it all I know I feel
like every car should have that feature
though like you brake and it holds your
car because it would have all boy did
that if you were like on a red light
yeah so you can scratch away and have to
worry that your car is slowly looking
for do you drive a Tesla
no that's she has a test on oh isn't it
have like crazy safety features that
like wouldn't allow you to get within
like 10 feet of a card I don't know if
that situation won't happen wouldn't
stop beeping like if I sort of EGFR but
beats don't work for you let me tell you
another story
really I had my BMW right and you know
like it beeps when it's there's like an
obstacle in its range so he's backing
into our garage space it's my baby baby
baby
he's like why have things why just think
[ __ ] beatin so much and well you could
go until I goes B but I did that okay
dad he [ __ ] up my [ __ ] bumper how
did that happen
your camera and I don't got something I
wouldn't be surprised like my cards have
all been [ __ ] up and it's a hundred
percent because of him have you ever
tried to get I've ever said to drive a
car that doesn't have a backup camera
since having a backup oh yes so they
forgot everything I do it every day in
my car I have a Mini Cooper dude the
[ __ ] here
like after I bought my car is when all
the cool [ __ ] happens the [ __ ] 2013 I
bought it bought it in 2012 it was the
2013 and I mean you need a backup camera
with a Mini Cooper
Joe I [ __ ] want it dude camera with
the cool cool but it's like my [ __ ]
Bluetooth you don't need a bluetooth but
it's sick my phone I have to plug it in
with a tiny little dongle and the dumb
goes like this big I'm like hey trust me
99 bucks for it I need a car that is
connected to my Alexa so I can literally
just be like Alexa ask my questions play
my music like that's the hands-free
experience I want wait I hate her but oh
yeah there is voice operated commands
but it's not as good it's [ __ ]
impossible to navigate all that [ __ ] is
pretty easy like in the link control car
the actual car audio voice-activated
system sucks my mind constantly calling
it's like ex-girlfriends I think he
might be telling you a story yeah I call
it my ex he's like ah the [ __ ] car
voice activation is a real [ __ ] you
know it's like all last part like recent
call if keeps on doing it could always
access I'm like not threatened they're
crazy
yeah that's always good to know he's
such a nice guy probably like didn't
want to feel about deleting the number
ah look just so crazy key taken hostage
nobody do ya
a fully powered lunch yeah and what if
he's looking for a crazy good time just
a quick one why are you putting [ __ ] in
her head I'm just I'm just helping her
we're trying to help where's that hell
where is helping her become detective my
husband I'm constantly worried he's
gonna realize he married down so I'm
just like yeah Wow
he's just like a good one I mean he's
too good for me Wow you're the boss he's
the only person in this group who has a
husband who married down
yeah cuz the rest of us all married oh
yes yeah I mean he would say yeah I
didn't mean to compliment you
but you did oh I don't - you burn our
wars in trash in you guys are all trash
no that was a previous thing that's
really not whatever
[Music]
you